[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday july 20th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
a major cyber security bug detected in a
widely used piece of software has been
given a new description
an endemic vulnerability
when it was discovered last year members
of the biden administration warned that
the bug in the software called log 4j
was one of the worst vulnerabilities
they had ever seen
the flaw allowed hackers to gain remote
access to computers so they could
extract data or install harmful software
log4j records user activity and their
behavior in applications and has been
downloaded millions of times it was one
of the most widely used tools for
collecting corporate information
apache software foundation the company
behind the program issued a patch
but still this month a government panel
issued a new report warning that the
glitch could still pose significant
risks
joining us to discuss the report and the
threat from the log for j bug is our
cyber security reporter dustin boltz
hi dustin thanks for being here thanks
for having me you know dustin we hear
the term endemic and a lot of people
think about you know diseases maybe some
of us might think about the change in
covid19 from a pandemic to an endemic
but we're talking about cyber security
here so what does it mean in this case
in this case um this government panel
concluded that the log4j cybersecurity
issue
is endemic because it is
so pervasive
so widespread because of the ubiquity of
the software affected here
that it is going to persist as a
significant risk to
companies and everyday users for
for a long time
this could be for a decade or more
a risk that we see that hackers are able
to exploit for surreptitious uh
espionage for other malicious purposes
and the reason for that is that in
addition to the software being so
widespread that's affected here there
are just enduring challenges with
getting people to
patch their software in order to address
the issue but also the
flaw is something that is very easy for
hackers to use and it also allows
hackers to potentially burrow rather
deeply into affected networks so it's
just sort of a
a very very significant risk when you
sort of add all those things together
apart from finding that this risk was
going to be endemic were there other big
takeaways from the report
yeah it's sort of a glass is half full
glass half empty situation because this
report
concluded that while this is a serious
risk that's going to continue for some
time
we actually haven't seen it be as bad as
a lot of people initially feared so as i
mentioned you know there were the fears
that this could be like the worst cyber
security flaw on record but uh according
to this government review there are no
significant episodes where this flaw was
used to disrupt or affect critical
infrastructure and generally there just
hasn't been nearly the level of serious
chaos and and harm caused by it now
there are lots of caveats to that for
starters the government can really only
assess what they know about and that
relies heavily on what businesses report
to the government so there could be tons
of
issues out there that have not been
reported in addition there's you know
the possibility that a lot of networks
were compromised and and are affected by
this flaw but just don't know it
themselves um
given those caveats though it is
surprising to a lot of people that we
haven't seen some sort of you know
massive headline grabbing attack that
was linked back to this lock for jflaw
i want to talk a little bit about the
panel that put out this report they're
called the cyber safety review board can
you tell us a little bit about them and
how they get their authority yeah
absolutely they uh this is a board
housed under the department of homeland
security it's loosely modeled on the
national uh transportation safety board
which people might be familiar with you
know investigating train derailments and
and plane crashes and that sort of
nature uh you know they'll come in and
sort of review the episodes and issue
reports on sort of what went wrong the
idea for this board is to basically do
the same but with like major national
cyber security crises
analyze them look at what the problems
are issue recommendations to businesses
and to government agencies and so forth
and try to you know improve broader
cyber security as a result so this was
their inaugural report they've put out
this big warning
how do they want companies to address
this problem the board also issues some
recommendations about sort of you know
how companies and government can work
better together you know they really
stress the importance of information
sharing between the private sector and
the government
that the faster those things can be done
the faster you know the network
defenders the people that the cyber
security agencies are able to sort of
issue recommendations and help people in
need so that's another uh important
thing as well additionally i think you
know there's just the hope and
expectation that that people will be
vigilant about the about the issue you
mentioned coven 19 earlier you know
we're sort of in the syndemic phase with
the virus where it comes and goes uh
and people sort of maybe address their
personal behavior somewhat responding to
that and i think uh the hope from the
board here is that with log4j and with
other cyber security issues that you
know people uh especially cyber security
professionals pay attention to those
threats and respond accordingly you know
with if there is sort of an outbreak of
a certain type of attack it's very
important to be following that and
respond and pivot as needed when that
does occur
all right that's our reporter dustin
volts thanks so much for joining us
dustin thanks so much
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you